[Music]
you
hey youtubers defenders hype so I'll
explain what's going on in this viral
trailer but they confirmed the release
date is August 18th for all the episodes
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC every week there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs that Netflix just
launched for defenders including this
footage here so let's start with a viral
trailer footage then I'll talk about the
viral website they launched on tumblr so
this footage is of them in Midland
circle going down in the elevator with
that giant hole that the hand was
building at the end of daredevil season
2 we never found out what that was but
this is the elevator it implies that the
hand built an elevator and it's going
down this giant shaft the defenders are
going down to see what's going on the
newspaper here talks about a lost city
so that's probably what the hand is
looking for and that could be from the
Iron Fist comics there are seven known
capital cities of heaven but during the
immortal Iron Fist run you learned that
there's a mysterious 8th city that's
like this hellish realm that serves as
the prison for all the evils of the
world
so now doesn't that sound like something
that the hand is trying to unleash so
that's a little bit different because
it's just the immortal weapons from the
Iron Fist comics from the different
capital cities of heaven teaming up to
focus their cheese to block off that 8th
city from the rest of Earth and the rest
of the other capital cities so that has
some prime Iron Fist comic book [ __ ]
going down right here
you're not gonna believe this
why are the Yakuza taking a home
Gary fleshly
you'd hit the button
tell me when it does
[Music]
you see Luke Cage so this looks like it
happens sometime later in the run of
episodes because as of the end of Luke
Cage he's still stuck in sigue prison so
in the first episode or first couple of
episodes of defenders they're gonna have
to figure out how to get him out
daredevil is wearing his old school mask
for a minute for a brief minute I
thought that might be iron fist and I
was like oh [ __ ] is he actually wearing
the cowl
nope not yet because this is Danny ran
down in the corner here he does have a
haircut though so the stars of Iron Fist
said that about 6 months past between
the end of that show in the beginning of
defenders they confirmed the release
date is gonna be August 18th that's on a
Friday so it's about 6 months they
weren't lying the Netflix shows tend to
move in real time the same way the
Marvel movies do so like when a movie
comes out a year after another movie
it's been about a year in the movie
universe so the other big thing you
might notice about this is the big
villain of defenders is going to be
Sigourney Weaver we only know that her
name is Alexandra but it's her voice
that's the voice of the elevator saying
going down so just heavily implying that
she in the hander watching them and now
that we know that there are different
factions of the hand different fingers
if you will Alexandra might be one of
the leaders of another faction or just
like one of the big bosses of the entire
hand itself and every member at the end
of iron fist
bakudo said that there was somebody
above him in his organization the hand
that was a very eager to work with Danny
Rand as the iron fist what use do you
have the iron fist
you know when I was a child my mother
told me the story of the sack man a sort
of boogey man who shows up if
disobedient children's homes and steals
them or in his sack to sell them
it's nonsense really but it kept us in
line nobody wanted to be captured by him
so what you want your own personal sack
man oh not just mine there's someone in
our organization who's very anxious to
work with you we're going to change the
world
the promises I've made you're still in
place I'll help you realign your Chi so
you can access the Iron Fist again I'll
help you become what you were meant to
be now that was more about the hand
using him as a deterrent to people that
would stop them from achieving their
goals so the funny thing about this is
there's a new theory I'm not sure if I
totally believe it yet there's not a lot
of evidence for it but because Danny's
mother had ties to Madame Gao meaning
his mother was connected to the hand
somehow that Alexandre is secretly his
mother I don't think that's the case
that would blow me away if they did that
but she's implied to be much more
powerful than bakudo even Elektra that's
being resurrected by another faction of
the hand who's implied to have some
crazy demon like spirit possessing her
the demon that the hand worships but the
new wrinkle and the mythology that they
introduced during iron fist is that
there are different factions so the
people that you saw during daredevil
season two is a different part of the
hand than the people that you saw during
iron fist so let me know what you guys
think about this but the Tumblr site
there's a viral tumblr site that's just
a new york post that just has a bunch of
fake news articles talking about rand
financial the Meacham's taking over Rand
enterprises so this is presumably set
way before iron fist starts there's an
ad for colleen wings dojo the wing way
that's so awesome
if you haven't seen it there's an ad for
that playing on youtube now it's almost
like they're trying to hypnotize you
into joining the hand because colleen
wing is part of the hand learn
self-defense the wing way and build
self-confidence and self-esteem
are you prepared to defend yourself come
down to our dojo in Chinatown for your
free class today it will change your
life
you see articles all down the bottom for
the other defenders Rand Rises Luke Cage
talking about how he gets thrown back in
prison
where's daredevil as of the end of
season 2 in Jessica Jones Three's
Company so the other one here
earth-shaking groundbreaking is talking
about the building the big giant hole at
the end of daredevil season 2 you have
to August but let me know what are all
your questions about the Marvel Netflix
universe the mythology what kind of
bonus videos do you guys want me to do
till it gets here they'll be doing a lot
of stuff at Comic Con but I'm expecting
that the first real trailer will drop
way before then so maybe in the next
month or two because they're still kind
of winding down on promoting Iron Fist
last big awesome piece of news is they
just started shooting Jessica Jones
season two if they haven't started today
then it's gonna be sometime in the next
week they've been putting up fliers all
over the Upper West Side of New York so
you might be able to spot them filming
really soon in daredevil season 3
Charlie Cox confirmed will start
shooting later this year so not quite at
the same time as Jessica Jones but
really soon daredevil is still kind of
like their marquee show so they want to
make sure it's as solid as possible so
once we see some of what's going on in
defenders we can start guessing about
how they're gonna follow up with
daredevil season 3 but there's a big
rumor that there might be a thor
ragnarok trailer dropping real soon if
that turns out to be true I'll post it I
don't really believe it but I'm gonna
keep my eyes peeled
agents have shield is back in legends of
tomorrow's having its finale so I'll try
to get all those videos out as fast as
possible
while you wait for that to post you can
click here for a brand new game of
Thrones promo and you can click here for
all my Marvel Netflix videos thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video